معنا من كيف عضو البرلمان الاوكراني كيرا
رودي كام اهلا بك معنا
اريد ان اعرف منك اي دلائل تعتمد عليها
القياده الاوكرانيه في نفي الاعلانات
الروسيه عن السيطره الكامله على ضخمه
شكرا
اولا دعني اذكركم
انه
مره سبعه او ثمانيه مرات على ادعاءات
روسيا في سيطرتها على باتموت
والجانب الاوكراني يثق بقواته العسكريه
وفي الصحفيين الدوليين الذين سوف يكونوا
بمقدورهم النفي او تاكيد تلك التصريحات
لكن بالنسبه للجانب الروسي لا يوجد اي
صحفيين لتاكيد ما يصدر عنهم من بيانات ان
قواتنا العسكريه
تقدم تلك التصريحات بناء على ما يرونه على
الارض وفي مناطق محدده من باخمد
وهذا يدفع يدفعنا انطلاقا من المنطقه الذي
تحمله تلك البيانات ان نصدقها
ونتذكر ان روسيا منذ الخريف الماضي لم
تحقق اي نصره اي نصر لذا لابد لها ان تظهر
تحقيق اي نصر لشعبها وخاصه من خلال
الزياره الاخيره التي قام بها الى مجموعه
الدول السبع وجامعه الدول العربيه
ولكن هناك تصريحات اوكرانيه رئاسيه فهم
منها انها اعتراف ومن ثم تراجع اضافه الى
ان الجيش الاوكراني لو كان
يسيطر فعلا لكان بامكانه تقديم بعض ادله
العسكريه على اماكن تواجده على المناطق
التي يتواجد بها وعلى الكثير من
البراهين التي يمكن ان يقدمها ليرد على
الجانب الروسي الذي يبدو مجمعا هذه المره
بجيشها وبقوات الفاغنر وقوات الشيشانيه
على هذا الكلام بعد الخلافات التي عصفت
بينهم
هذه ليست للمره الاولى التي تزعم فيها
روسيا بانها سيطرت على بخمه ولكننا نحن لا
نرد
حول تغطيه مواقع قواتنا
لتسريبها للقوات الروسيه تذكروا انهم
قالوا بانهم سيطروا عليك بانهم سوف
يسيطرون على كيف خلال ثلاثه ايام
والبلاد برمتها خلال اسابيع هذه كلها
تصريحات غير حقيقيه حول النصر
وتجافي الصواب لذا
لا بد لنا ان ننتظر يوم او اثنين
لنعرف كيف سوف تتجلى الصوره بشكلها
الحقيقي حتى اللحظه لم نسمع اي تصريحات من
قبل الجانب الاوكراني
بشان مساله فوزي القوات مجموعه باجنر
احتلالها
لبخمت بالكامل خلال اليومين القادمين سوف
نرى بان روسيا تقوم بتضليل
بشن حمله تظلل المعلومات وهذا جزء من
البروباندا التي اتبعتها في العدم ما من
قصص النجاحات للجيش الروسي في اي مكان اخر
وليس وتفتقر الى اي نجاحات على مر الاشهر
السبع او ثمانيه الماضيه وكان جنودها
يموتون بعدد كبيره دون اي سبب فقط لسبب
واحد وهو تدمير بلادنا شكرا جزيلا لك عضو
الاوكرانيه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات